dann nochmals lukrativ willkommen wir
heute am donnerstag
herzlich willkommen jetzt
selbstverständlich am dienstag meine
lieben freunde an welchem tag auch sonst
einer neuen episode take that you save
ich zeige euch heute mal wieder meine
tik tok der woche also die tricks die
ich besonders cool lustig traurig schön
lustig schön traurig lustig die fresse
du lachen ich würde sagen wir fangen ja
gar mit dem ersten tik tok
[Musik]
dass aber auch geladen
lukas ist in ca du bekommst von mir auf
jeden fall der in der woche
wie lange geht das video noch
bruder hast du die ganze luft auf erden
in die johann michael ritsch jbbl top4
cockpit bei einem formel 1 tätig und bin
einfach durch befürchte erst heftig
betrunken ich finds halt wirklich
bewundernswert wie wenig schamgefühl
einige leute haben der nächste tipp topp
user möchte die weighted blanket
challenge machen dabei geht es darum
dass man halt eine gewichtete decke über
sich schmeißt und auf jeden fall kommt
dann der vater aus versehen rein die
treppe hoch und wird einfach selbst was
dann passiert ist sie in banken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja das nächste tipp doch video ist kein
fehler sondern eine lustige situation im
stall solid einer der
ich meine wer kennt es nicht einfach mal
im staunen lied komponieren mit dem auto
vor allem was aber definitiv jeder von
euch kennt es folgende situation so war
es so die wahrheit wir haben letztens so
viele leute die kommentare geschrieben
lukas 2009 10 ist nur klatschen die sein
zimmer gelaufen und jetzt ist einfach
nur noch es ist die wahrheit
ich weiß es jetzt oft sagen aber es ist
einfach die wahrheit und das ist ein
richtig trauriger moment und seinen
freunden eine kleine fliegen wie die
verweigert worden
[Musik]
ja ich glaube das hat weh getan was
definitiv auch weh getan hat ist das was
die folgende top userin macht und zwar
will sie mit ihrem ganzen körper ein xxl
polier einsteigen
das bekommt sie auch hinkommt allerdings
nicht wieder raus also seht einfach
selbst
ich hatte da drin schon längst eine
panikattacke bekommen leute lasst meine
daumen hoch bei diesem video hier da und
bei 70.000 ich weiß es ist eine menge
70.000 geschafft dann wird mein nächster
stop video ich hab das ist keine gute
idee gut
ich will nicht sagen das ist die
wahrheit aber das könnt ihr mir genauso
passieren beim nächsten personen haben
ein video auf twitter hochgeladen in dem
sie versucht haben entschlossen eine
colaflasche rhein zu schmeißen da gibt
es einige videos von leute das sagen
geschafft haben dann ist die cola
verstehen luft geflogen keine ahnung was
die schaffen es allerdings nicht und am
ende ja seht einfach selbst was am ende
passiert
juli in london ehe getrennt
[Musik]
auch genau mein erster sieg doch users
auf jeden fall mit dem trend mit
gegangen hat sich sein ganzes haus
mittels haushaltsgegenständen eine bahn
bzw einem einen parcours für einen
tischtennisball aufgebaut hat es fast
geschafft noch dann am ende ja ich
schaue einfach selbst und ich glaube
jeder jeder wirklich jeder hat da schon
mal gemacht so mit
noch folgen
nein
ist krasser am arsch als mein arsch
das nächste video hat jemand an einem
flughafen aufgenommen
[Musik]
irgendwie besteht diese serie daraus ist
ich extrem viele tik tok zeige meine
reaktion darauf ist einfach mein humor
für marsch oder es so die wahrheit
die us-boys was ist wirklich meinen
dating life international meine lieben
freunde beim nächsten tipp topp könnt
ihr einfach mal selbst aus mitmachen und
zwar schaut die jetzt die ganze zeit auf
euren screenen nicht blinzeln die ganze
zeit das herz angucken
ich werde euch auch nicht erschrecken
oder irgendwie so oder euch verarscht
oder keine ahnung was schaut einfach in
die mitte von dem screen und leicht
werden sich gegenstände die an eurem
zimmer anguckt vergrößern und ich würde
sagen ihr schaut einfach mal weg in 321
und jetzt wegschauen meine lieben
freunde konzentriert euch einfach auf
irgendeinen gegenstand in eurem raum
oder beispielsweise auf mich hier gerade
und ihr seht schon das vergrößert sich
[Musik]
auf jeden fall das tik tok der woche
meine lieben freunde dafür jetzt mal ein
immer dienstags computer und ein video
der woche also herzlichen glückwunsch an
jacob punkt fj wunsch komme nun
allerdings zum nächsten text video
meiner lieben freund und ich habe hier
wirklich fast geweint so emotional ist
das ganze
[Musik]
es ist einfach schön und dann nachhaltig
doch irgendwie erkannt hey luca schaut
sich gerne videos von diesen komischen
aufgeblasenen dinosauriern an und findet
die ganz cool
doch einfach mal eins so ein dinosaurier
einen salto das messe ticker videos eine
optische täuschung mit einem allerdings
sehr komischen ende mit dem man glaube
ich nicht gerechnet hat aber schauen
einfach so wie ihr da wahrscheinlich
gerade vor eurem handy sind oder vor dem
computer habe ich auch da gesetzen und
dachte mir wow ich dachte jetzt da
springt einfach drauf
er klingelt denn jetzt bei mir da jetzt
gerade bei mir ein paket geliefert wird
würde ich sagen zeige ich euch noch ein
letztes tickt doch video bei dem ich von
einer freundin mit müll beworfen wurde
danke noch mal dafür carola an der
stelle würde ich allerdings die heutige
folge tik tok users auf band meine
lieben freunde wie bereits gesagt wenn
ihr 70.000 leicht staat werde ich ein
video demnächst auf die schokoladen wo
ich mich in einem xxl hol dir einsätze
last also einen daumen hoch unter dem
video das schreibt gerne euren texten
haben und in die kommentare falls ihr
eventuell in die nächste folge tic toc
tools kommen wollte und jetzt
ich muss dem paket menschen jetzt mal
aufmachen
[Musik]